[Música]
tiempo para la información económica en
directo a américa por eso está con
nosotros nuestro compañero jorge hurtado
jorge vamos a comenzar hablando con
datos del reino unido como deja boris
johnson la economía de este país bueno
sin duda en la inflación ahí sigue
siendo un gran desafío en general el
índice de precios aumentó en un año el
9,1 por ciento la cifra más alta en 40
años el banco central de inglaterra ha
dicho que la inflación anual allí podría
llegar al 11 por ciento y por ello
comenzaron a subir los tipos de interés
también el desempleo es una de las
quejas de los ingleses ahí el dato
aumentó recientemente y se ubica en el
3,8 por ciento mientras que en abril la
economía también se contra un 0,3 por
ciento aumentando los temores de una
desaceleración económica quien sustituya
a johnson no podrá hacer mucho para
contrarrestar el impacto de la subida de
los precios mundiales de la energía y
los alimentos- otro de los retos para el
nuevo primer ministro será bajar la
deuda del reino unido- que supera los
2,4 billones de dólares otro desafío
también es el break sito porque seis
años después de que el reino unido-
votará a favor de abandonar la unión
europea y dos años y medio después de
que en vigencia reino unido- y el bloque
continúan definiendo las reglas
comerciales con las que van a operar
forraje seguimos en europa profundizamos
en ese proyecto de ley en francia que
quiere ayudar a las familias a combatir
la inflación -juan el paquete asciende a
20 mil 300 millones de dólares está
destinado como decías a destinar a
ayudar a los hogares a hacer frente a
las consecuencias de la guerra en
ucrania incluido el aumento de los
precios de la energía y los alimentos
el plan se suma al llamado escudo de
tarifas del gas y de la electricidad que
se ha prolongado hasta diciembre y que
tendrá un costo adicional de 15 mil
millones de euros el ministro de
finanzas y economía pero no le maire
atribuyó este escudo de tarifas que
francia sea el país con la tasa de
inflación más baja en la zona euro hoy
es el 5,8 por ciento anual registrado en
junio
'jorge hablamos también del dólar porque
está muy cerca de alcanzar la paridad
con el euro que es lo que está pasando
pero el dólar estadounidense ha subido
tanto que por primera vez en 20 años su
valor es casi igual al del euro la
subida del dólar se debe principalmente
a que la reserva federal está subiendo
los tipos de interés de forma más
agresiva
centrales de otros países esto para
frenar la inflación más alta en eeuu que
es de cuatro décadas las subidas de los
tipos provocan un aumento de los
rendimientos de los bonos del tesoro de
eeuu de esto es llamativo para los
inversores que buscan rendimientos más
elevados pero esta demanda de valores en
esa moneda a su vez impulsa el valor del
dólar una moneda más fuerte afecta a las
empresas estadounidenses que hacen
negocios en el extranjero la subida
también erosiona los beneficios de las
empresas que dependen de las ventas en
el extranjero y hace que sus ingresos
valgan menos cuando los convierten a
dólares y lo llevan a eeuu
otro efecto también hwan será en las
arcas públicas cuando los gobiernos
europeos compren energía ya que
mayoritariamente estas transacciones se
realizan en dólares lo que la vuelve más
cara en un momento en que los precios
del petróleo y el gas ya están de por sí
altos el euro ha perdido un 9% en lo que
va del año y un 13% en los últimos 12
meses de su valor seguimos hablando de
este fenómeno inflacionario pero
centrado en américa del sur así se ve el
aumento de los precios en américa del
sur es q si excluimos a venezuela y
argentina los países más alta inflación
en la región son brasil paraguay uruguay
chile y colombia
el chile por ejemplo con un contexto de
cambios políticos este aumento de los
precios está creando un malestar social
y se convierte en un desafío para el
nuevo gobierno de gabriel boliche los
chilenos dicen que sus hábitos de compra
han cambiado totalmente para poder
llegar a fin de mes escuchemos
es decir allá voy a comprar tanto tiro y
ahora no se puede hacer eso
todo eso es menos que hace comprar tres
kilos de tomates de que consta el kilo y
medio o dos kilos también en argentina
se le suman los temores generados por
las crisis políticas tras la renuncia
del ministro de economía que ha generado
un aumento de los precios mientras el
tipo de cambio informal se dispara la
subida de precios se hacen más notorias
en los productos importados escuchamos
que dicen los argentinos si hoy hay dos
importadores ya me llamaron que se
normalizó la entrega pero bueno en
aumento funde un 20 por ciento no
esperaron a ver si se podía hacer un
poco menos mandaron un 20 por ciento de
aumento y bueno y si quiere la
mercadería
pagas con el 20% yo pienso que hay que
esperar que esto se tranquilice un poco
pues algo ya ha vivido hace años o
resultado con información económica
muchas gracias como siempre